what is up guys it is Jerry oh let me
turn on the radio Ryan and I just got
out of Captain America the Winter
Soldier and I'm on my way to his place
right now so we can shoot our reasons to
see but I figured I'd check in with you
guys do a little first impression for
you I feel like I ought to start out
just to be fair to go to the film and to
you guys by saying that I've become kind
of fatigued by these big 10 pull movies
in general you know it feels to me like
sort of every week there's a new clip or
a new trailer or new something or other
for something that's big and epic and
crazy and buildings are exploding and
people are running around and it's super
intensive so I've sort of found it
difficult lately to really look forward
to stuff like this but I do in general
really like Marvel's movies and their
approach to things and Captain America
is no exception I actually quite enjoyed
this movie it's definitely action-packed
but it's sort of like an espionage you
know political thriller just as much as
it is you know a superhero movie the big
themes are sort of freedom and Trust and
it's interesting to see that sort of
tests you know because you've got Steve
Rogers Captain America who is the ideal
leader and soldier and all that and he's
dealing with a shield that he doesn't
really agree with and who he doesn't
know he can ultimately trust and things
only get more tangled and more hairy
from there this movie is fun still like
there's still that you know comic book
Marvel you know dialog and on everything
but it is also more intense it's more
serious you know the stakes have been
certainly raised and the movie does a
good job with it I'm always interested
in who they get to direct these things
and this time around it's the Russo
brothers who are known for Arrested
Development and that's something I
thought was really cool of because you
know again Marvel it chooses these
out-of-the-box people to direct these
movies you know it's not
West all the time so yeah you know this
movie has its own identity it can stand
alone but it also feels at home in the
Marvel Universe to me which is cool
Chris Evans is great as Captain America
again and I really like what he does in
this character I really like watching
him and I really like watching Captain
America's adventures I was a little
worrying about a Captain America movie
now that they've completely brought him
into the present you know because the
event is a different thing you know but
as far as Captain America specifically
goes I like the first one especially for
its retro period piece vibe but I also
quite enjoyed this one they brought in
Black Widow for a bigger part in this
and thankfully she's very essential to
the plot and they handled the character
great you know it's nice to see that
they're really embracing Black Widow and
you know female superheroes and having
them work as equals and also you've got
Samuel Jackson is Nick Fury you have
Anthony Mackie joining the cast as
Falcon and I wish they would have used
him more but I really like Anthony
Mackie and I really liked having him in
this kind of giving Captain America
sidekick you've got also Robert Redford
Cobie Smulders is back in this one and
they gave her a bit bigger of a role
which is nice Frank Grillo is in this
who I'm always happy to see it get work
there are a lot of fun little
appearances that I won't spoil for you
guys but but you'll recognize some
people and and those are definitely
treats from this movie so yeah I enjoyed
it it's definitely if you're a Marvel
fan you know I'm not an aficionado of
the comics by any stretch of the
imagination but I imagine if you like
Marvel's movies and all you'll
definitely enjoy this I've heard people
say it's Marvel's Dark Knight which I
don't know if I completely agree with
because it's just the identities it just
doesn't feel like the same kind of movie
and I don't I don't know I don't I don't
like it more than the Avengers but I
certainly enjoyed it and it's certainly
one of the ones at least as of right now
that I enjoyed more than some of the
other recent Marvel films do you know
like I liked Iron Man 3 and Thor 2 and
those movies each have interesting
things that they brought to the table
that I wasn't expecting but as a whole
movie I think I like this one better
than some of the other recent ones and
there are some parts in this plot that
had me going there's some there are some
things that I didn't expect
you'll see you'll see so it's definitely
worth checking out and I quite liked it
so um hopefully you know we'll see how
I'm feeling when we when I talked to
Ryan but I'm definitely feeling positive
on this definitely think it's worth
checking out and you know they did
actually bring in you know more stuff
for the characters to chew on especially
in the political climate today it's nice
to see Captain America standalone as
this voice for you know freedom and and
all the American ideals even if the
people he's working for aren't
necessarily on the up-and-up
that makes it very relatable in a sense
because it's like we live in a time
where it's hard to tell who you can
trust and who was on the up-and-up
so having Captain America be you know
the spirit of America you know incarnate
through a superhero and not just the
system itself it is really cool I was
enjoying seeing these Captain America
movies too because when they first set
out to do it I wasn't sure how they were
gonna be able to manage it but I really
liked having Steve Rogers around in in
today's you know action movie and
superhero movie climate because it's
nice to have at least one guy who has a
strong sense for his values and his
moral compass and his beliefs you know I
mean I'm all for these conflicted
superheroes and you know these smartass
superheroes and stuff like that but it's
nice to have at least one guy who really
knows his values and is an upstanding
you know character in in the way that
Steve Rogers is you know he's from a
different time and I like that essence
about him so anyway what did you guys
think if you saw this what's your
favorite Marvel movie anything comment
below and I'll is always like and
subscribe and until next time I'm Gerry
Captain America the Winter Soldier is
the film Cheers